كثيره وفي قضيه
896 وفاه و400 جريح في مرضتها
وعدد كبير ايضا وفي عثمانيه 52 وفاه
والفين 2073 جريح في كيس 700 وفاه
ومجموع الوفيات كله للاسف الشديد 5000
مواطنا فقدوا حياتهم
31 الف ويزيد جريحا اسال الله الرحمه بكل
مواطنين الذين فقدوا حياتهم واسال الله
الشفاء لكل الجرحى اسال الله السلامه
لشعبنا كله
وبالنسبه وفيما يخص جرحانه قد استفرغنا
1424 اسعاف واثنين وثلاثه واربعين مكت
مستشفى ميداني كما وظفنا الكثير من
فرق الطبيه
292 طبيبا ارسلناهم الى منطقه الكوارث
كما هنالك 78 وحده مداخله وحده التدخل
عاجل في منطقه الكوارث
وجرحى الاسكندرون تم ارسالهم بالاسعاف عن
طريق الباب الى مستشفى مرسين
والليل الماضيه كما تعلمون 98 جريحا تم
نقلهم عبر سفينه وزاره الدفاع الى مرسين
في مستشفى مرسين يوجد 170 شخص جريح في
العينين المركزه ومجموع الجرحى 590 جريح
يتلقون مستشفى مرسين واما في هطيت فالجرحى
تم ارسالهم
الى مستشفى
اضنه الان في مستشفى اضنه
هناك 220 جريحا في العينين المركزه
ومجموعه عدد الجرحى 600 جريح يواصلون تلقي
العلاج في مستشفى اضنه وكذلك في الريحانيه
للجرحى
زلزال واما الجرح الذين جراحاتهم خطيره
فقد فننقلهم بالطائرات والمروحيات الى
انقره اسطنبول وقد تم نقله 300 جريح
تقريبا بهذا الشكل مواطنون الاعزاء
تركيا
تسعى حكومه التركيه تسعى بكل قوتها
لتضميد هذه الجراحات
ونشكر مواطنين الذين يسعون بكل جهدهم
لتضمير جراحات اخوانهم يجب ان لا ننسى ان
كل الكوارث التي واجهناها معا ونجحنا في
مواجهتها نجحنا في ذلك بالتعاون والتضامن
والتكاتف واليوم كذلك الامر ننتظر من
شعبنا الدعاء شكرا جزيلا